wearing his for the brand t-shirt is
none other than Pat McAfee I would say
you're a former pro ball punter but once
a pro ball punter forever a pro ball
Punk yeah that means a lot you're a pro
ball human and that round of applause
was for you in this operation you have
here for those of you that don't know
Rich Eisen is running a first-class
operation here is makeup lady very very
nice thank you she saw my face brought
out a bucket went to work and it's very
very great to be here you're a handsome
man that is a lie you know I can't even
tell that you're wearing makeup he she
did a whole Bob Ross situation with my
face trees on my forehead I mean it was
a wild scene I've never been a part of
something like this but it's been
awesome to be here good to see you sir
great to be high eleven the Southern
California situation this morning I woke
up took some vitamins and stared out at
the sea for about 25 30 minutes to tell
you what it was really awesome single
that order was it in that order yep it
was well I went I showered first okay
got the weekend rust off then I stare at
the sea for about 25 30 minutes and a
homeless guy was tripping on some drugs
comes running by that was kind of its
own little spectacle for 15 minutes
welcome to Southern California is a lot
then what in the vitamins where did the
vitamins come into play huh it's
probably the reason why I can't go back
in the NFL tomorrow because this
particular batch of vitamins that I use
but it makes me feel good and I enjoy my
lokay in the ocean looks a lot better on
these particular vitamins as well how
many times did you did you get that
letter from the NFL trying to make sure
that you you are not taking whatever
supplements that you might be on right
now well the random drug tests you know
those are only for peds
performance-enhancing drugs and I always
wondered why they would test me because
if I was to take off my shirt yes it is
that of an adolescent I look bad I look
like worse than you probably what
shouldn't happen by the way that was not
a shot at you though it's okay I take it
as that though I'm built like a barrel
okay but the street drug tests it's only
an annual so once you take it
celebration begins here we go will often
run it unless you get arrested for any
alcohol or drug related charge which I
allegedly had then I got tested eight
times a month for 27 months that was
rough so did you ever did you ever like
cork a game where you leverage like 60
yards upon oh yeah and then all of a
sudden you got that random letter in
your locker
yeah happen yeah I used to look at it as
like a shot from Roger Goodell if I
didn't get tested like oh you didn't
think I had that good of a game you
didn't think you should randomly drug
test me
I had a 60 some yard ball Roger come get
this pass cus I did so well I should be
randomly dead that's Terry to Leakey
when Vinny it was he's like 50 years old
knocking down 50 yard field goals he
gets tested the next day you don't if he
doesn't I think he takes it as a shot to
it's the new thing in the NFL if you
don't get randomly tested Roger Goodell
just doesn't think you had a good enough
game it's not your father's NFL anymore
no lack if he's trying to say no way
gotta get that piss up okay
urine sorry I don't know what we're
allowed to say here no it's okay so um
look at that Mick I'm just seeing myself
now on the camera yeah how do you like
it I'll tell you what you Hollywood
people really live a nice dad oh you got
to come out here from every night so
you're still living in Indianapolis is
that what you're still yeah yeah full
time I like the people there great
Hoosier hospitality is a real thing were
you from originally Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania
yeah where the ballers blowing the
players play so the Steelers were your
team growing it's my dad steam yeah he
used to just throw the remote at the TV
every time Kordell Stewart did something
wrong that's why you see watching my dad
on Sundays is what made me not be a fan
of teams and be a fan of players because
his life was just ruined anytime Jerome
Bettis or chemo vol all Hoffman or any
of them ever know that accident just
came out right knee injury I was bad I
saw my dad break a couple remotes in
almost TVs after bill cowers chin comes
out and starts spitting at people so I
just became a fan of players instead of
teams who was your player growing up
love Deion Sanders love Randy Moss I
like people with personality that's why
I love Conor McGregor it's a shame that
he had to fight a guy that wrestled a
bear as a child he had no chance there I
like personality I was about to say
let's get into that then yeah what did
you make of the of the match on Saturday
night I think in MMA right mixed martial
arts yes I think it's one of those
sports where if you're rich and
comfortable it's kind of tough you know
what I mean
and if you get a hundred million dollar
payday I think it's almost you get a
little bit too comfortable Conor
McGregor
showed up in great shape though which I
didn't I didn't expect as if I have
$100,000,000 there's no way I'm gonna be
rolling and training at 5:00 a.m. with
other dudes trying to break my legs
that's neither here nor there that
khabib character though is why I
literally watched a video him this
morning a bear when he was seven in
Dagestan wrestling and I don't know what
Dagestan is but he wrestled a bear it is
right there Patrick yeah look at him
he's taking his leg it's a double leg
shoot - I mean if you can't Jackie moon
wrestle a bear this guy really did that
and it was seven I know what I don't
know again what your folks how they
raised you yeah I know how mine raised
me yeah
hey you know VHS was just beginning
mm-hmm when I was seven yeah I don't
know again if it was more readily
available if my folks would say hey
today seven-year-old rich
let's go wrestle a bear you know and
we'll [ __ ] we'll we'll shoot it we'll
have it there forever you'll have that
VHS copy forever see I think Tim McAfee
if a bear was available he would do it I
think you would have sent me in there I
think you would have just to kind of
test my coos there for a little bit I
think he would have I played soccer
growing up Yeah right okay and when I
was a child I flinched or something when
a guy like kicked I like flinched how
old were you uh probably eight seven or
eight and my dad would definitely go to
jail for this now he taped me to a fence
and through soccer balls at me so he
would prove that I didn't it wouldn't
hurt now walk me through this process
yeah absolutely so what type of tape was
it used it was duct tape yeah the real
thing was a real thing and my dad my dad
would definitely end up in jail if this
was anything anywhere near the world
we're in right now okay but I never
flinched again I'll tell you that once
you get a soccer ball right to the chest
while being taped to a fence by your dad
you're never gonna flinch again so I'm
assuming no headgear involved no no
that's what his nose probably happened I
got a big old sniffer it's probably from
a soccer ball hitting there I don't
remember CT city possibly coming right
off that fence Wow
okay so khabib wrestling a bear at age
seven is obviously not other realm I I
stepped into that wrong octagon with the
McAfee Pittsburgh family understood yeah
but to me again I'm like it's it's
amazing how folks are kind of
shocked that's somebody who wrestled a
bear at age seven yeah and is willing to
take knees feet for arms let's say it
how it is
you know let's see how it is sure there
are human cockfighter those fighters
right
they are legitimately human rooster
fighters whatever you want to call I
don't know what language are allowed to
use here I think let's be safe for work
as possible chicken fighters there are
human chicken fighters get one you said
it is still fine okay good it's like a
gladiator situation though you gotta
have a special thing in your brain to go
into this gladiator inside of a cage to
fight that's why whenever they start
going after these guys oh they're not
good people Connors a rout yeah he's
trying to kill a human that's what he's
actually trying to do now granted all
this stuff post fight I think it's good
for the UFC by the way cuz it's all
we're talking about yeah Dana White
having to act mad afterwards like oh
this is a stain on the UFC I'm so upset
that's relevant you've been no I but III
also said just full disclosure at the
top that in this day and age nobody's
ashamed of anything anymore and at least
I appreciated that I appreciated that
that he said that it was yes that he
said that this is bad and that this is
not right that's because there's a
potential lawsuit coming maybe so that
could be it to the old cya situation
what I appreciated that cuz he could
have come out and said you know too bad
if you don't like it as a matter of fact
you know you try and get in the ring and
you know got all barrel-chested about
this sort of thing I would have taken
offense to that action Dana is a good
businessman I think we can all agree
that Dana White's a good businessman
what they buy it for like a couple
million then they sell it for a couple
billion I mean rights the way it goes
but I think we're all talking about it
right now
huge Houston Texas and Dallas Cowboys
game last night Sunday Night Football
goes to overtime deshaun Watson getting
killed the entire night big game-winning
field goal what's everybody talking
about this morning though too big the
guy from Douga
where Dagestan you got it dogger Stan
jumping out of the cage and then a guy
in a red jacket clean cold clock and
Conor McGregor after the fight it's good
marketing it's good work is a WW people
would say it's a good work it was great
for UFC Pat McAfee here on the Rich
Eisen show so nice set you know thanks
man
so you're gonna hang out for the whole
hour with us here Chris Brock one's
gonna have a news update more if you
want to take phone calls we can do that
too with Pat McAfee 844 204 rich cuz
you're just hang them up for the whole
hour yep
what are you what are you what's your
scoop right now what do you are your
what are you up to is what I'm saying
cuz I know you're a bar stool you're not
bar stool anymore are you a free agent
or you I am a free agent
I am media free agent okay not really
hot in the streets but I am a free agent
it's like those guys that don't get
drafted but they never really played
they're free agents that's where I am
right now well I mean you took a real
risk leaving the NFL in a paycheck
joining bar stool yep at the sort of a
cent a bar stool hmm which is now a
large mogul operation glamorous anguish
why'd you do that why'd I quit and do
that I was just I wasn't enjoying
football team I wasn't enjoying the
business of the NFL that makes sense
I'll always be an NFL fan always be a
fan of the games the the football is in
general I love it I have a lot of
friends still playing I still watch
every single weekend I just wasn't
enjoying going to work anymore I it was
I was starting to feel as if I'm not the
right guy for the league anymore if that
makes sense I was I was falling in love
with stuff off the field more so than on
the field I would go and do philanthropy
stuff it would be like real fulfillment
and then I would I sold 10,000 tickets
to a comedy show a four night comedy
show in like 35 seconds or something in
Indiana and I was like man this is fun
and then I would do stand-up and people
would laugh for 35 minutes to 45 minutes
of a 90-minute show batting 500 not too
bad and then I would go to work and they
just I wasn't enjoying it anymore I was
like I'm kind of sick of kicking balls
whenever our offense fails it's not
really fulfilling its that's what you
started looking at I was kind of falling
out of love with kicking balls on fourth
downs and I cherished my time in the NFL
I love the friendships I created the
experiences I got a lot of money from it
I got to take care of my whole family I
got to take care of my friends I just
started falling out of love with it and
wanted to chase fulfillment and the
internet life was the way to go yeah it
sure was yeah we're doing okay over
there yeah and Pat McAfee show.com
the greatest comedic sports documentary
of all time alone alive what is that
about
what is that about well I never played
baseball grown-up okay my dad hated
baseball said it was boring had me play
soccer
wild move by the way also if he's gonna
tape you to a pole and and and fireballs
at you yeah better not baseball to be
honest with you I'm happy those are
soccer balls enough basics right
you're 100% right okay probably still
struggling to this day if they were
baseball understood my dad is sick of
seeing me look soft no I respect the
move hindsight 20/20 fifty-fifty Cam
Newton says I think I think I never
played baseball didn't even play catch
didn't even play catch growing up all my
friends played I never played t-ball
nothing never stepped into the diamond
so then the Washington wild things which
is a frontier league minor league team
outside of Pittsburgh reached out to me
and asked me if I wanted to start at
right field for them one night and
getting that bat and I said absolutely
of course so then we filmed it I'm miked
up the entire time my friends are doing
commentary I had three at-bats I started
a right field and we just we made a
documentary out of it and it is I don't
say this about a lot a lot of my stuff's
average like you shouldn't follow me on
Twitter I used to be good on Twitter not
so great anymore very average but this
documentary I'm very proud of okay by
the way I would disagree I follow you on
twitter I enjoy your commentary more
about pissed missiles every single
Saturday the brand needs by the way
those are words I've never said out loud
or into a microphone did it feel good
though getting that pissed missile I
know what it did it did I tweeted it the
one time when I tweeted at you about a
piss missile which is what you call what
these rockets 60 yards seven yard punts
that are seeing more commonly now in the
NFL yeah the brands the brands getting
some big Laurie I tweeted it and I wrote
it out and I might my thumb hovered
around the send button for a second I'm
like you know what I'll do it I'll do it
well they say if you have to think about
it you shouldn't do it I know that I
know that but I did it anyway the
greatest comedic sport the documentary
of all time available for 3.3 33 is that
an armed homage to your average night
rich don't be giving away too much ok
richness is all it's galactica feel ok
they could pre-order it right now for
three dollars and 33 cents and it's the
full 5 bucks when it's on the release
date of October 10th and then there's
all sorts of fun stuff that you can get
me the greatest raffle of all time the
growth the growth the growth involves
World Series tickets right the glut
superb all tickets I heard from some
lawyers I'm not allowed to say we're
giving away super bout okay no I got to
be careful
surround it but we got Super Ball
tickets we got world's Erie's tickets we
got Wrestlemania tickets we got a bunch
of these are on for an event why would
anybody want to get raffle tickets to
those events
well it's superb hours when these two
really good football teams play against
each other I don't know why our where
the outcomes okay oh yeah what if you
buy this documentary you could entered
into that New York I'm from New York I
thought you were talking about a guy
named Al no no the you're talking about
people he's superb ow oh it's really
what you're saying now sir it's the
accident before we take our first break
and then we'll get a news up I'm talking
about the bird with the big eyes yeah
you you love you uh just coming in full
circle about your dad and how much he
enjoys contact involving you yeah the
the the trendin holiday blow-up he must
have called you up like the proudest pop
of all time right yeah my dad enjoyed
that I didn't look soft out there yeah I
think that you blew him up you sized him
up and you took him right out to be I
did get drug tested her next day 100%
true yeah that was when the whole random
drug test started happened and yeah that
was when I got excited but that was not
a size up operation that was a blind
squirrel finding and nut I was running
as fast as I could have my eyes closed
and I just so happened to run into the
Olympic track star and I feel bad for
that guy because anytime I tackle
happens it looks like that his name just
gets smeared all over the Internet and
it's a real shame it's great for me real
shame for him you posterized somebody
patchy Oh Effie right in front of pigman
big-ass head man it's come homecoming
games in Indianapolis man it was awesome
it was absolutely awesome all right
we'll take a break Pat McAfee
professional baseball player is here on
the Rich Eisen show when we come back we
want to what else what's on the news
update that you have over there we're
gonna hear from Odell Beckham his
comments oh that was bad and JJ is
stirring things up stirring things up
correct from England and Shawn McVeigh I
just I want to run through a wall for
that guy I want to get your two cents on
the cojones the church bell cojones on
that man the fourth of an inch oh my
gosh Pat McAfee at McAfee show on
Twitter he's here on the riches
all right still scoreless in Cleveland
top three a one out man on first
Clevenger looking very I guess hater
like right with that hair that flowing
the flowing locks the flowing Mane Makai
hater is amazing no he's like a right
handed hater
Clevenger another kind of a degree
that's what's going on in the American
League divisional series Houston trying
to sweep out the as a professional
baseball player I appreciate you keeping
up yes Patrick McAfee professional
baseball player you can get the greatest
comedic sports documentary of all time
live now available for just three
dollars and 33 cents at Pat McAfee show
calm great plug right there among them
well look you know what as you know I
have been plugging the brand for quite
some time by the way you really by the
way that would be the name of my album
right now plugging the brand something
about that beard get a new beard new
look fresh you reimagine Rich Eisen you
just you just met my wife who just
strolled out here she's getting ready to
go to Lakers ooh yes who is she the host
of the official Lakers podcast and so
she kind of I think she likes the beard
yeah and then there's as you know
nothing there's not much up top not like
you I mean you got some serious cabbage
up there pal I used to have the long
hair to when I got arrested I looked
pretty terrible in a mugshot but it's my
hair I feel good about I use for hems
calm by the way no free ads on your show
but my show now normally wearing helmets
for as long as people do that normally
that normally does wreaks havoc on the
[Music]
[Laughter]
underwear with a lot more than manning
always had that big red splotches
forehead I got a little landing zone up
right guys that is large it's cuz it's
got a big brain in there though yeah big
old brain so up before we get to the
news update Pat and be honest with me
any honest with me how am i viewed in
the punting community no you we love you
okay we love you now granted not all
punters like matter or kickers matter
cuz there's a lot of there's a lot of
people out there that have been bad for
the brand of kicking and punting and
that's kind of what I try to bring
attention to is the people that are good
for the brand not bad for the brand
right but you were the og men you know
when Brian anchor got drafted there and
everybody lost their mind on set
you want in ahead and said that we were
people too and that meant a lot to us in
the locker room and the showers in our
beds at late at night dressed naked so
now now now I'm getting concerned it
shouldn't be when we're thinking about
you in intimate times it's goodies which
we I have done that numerous times no
you're the OG the Richard a man I'm the
George Washington to this situation yeah
yeah maybe Christopher Columbus you
sailed the seas I see yeah George
Washington was the it was Brian anger
yes Afton yeah absolutely he's a weapon
and a person I've seen Hamilton by the
way so I am sophisticated on this whole
thing but I would say you're Christopher
Columbus more than anything
you seem Hamilton huh yeah fantastic
yeah Aaron Burr played the guy that
killed my Aaron Burr when I once saw it
yeah
was it guy that killed Jesus in John
Legend's thing I did not yeah you know
what a bad guy I'm having trouble just
real-time connecting these pop-culture
dots I'm just assuming camera bottle is
in there somewhere
you know what Broadway if he's gonna sit
in with the news update brought to you
by the new the 2019 honda pilot seating
for up to eight and available
intelligent traction management you can
haul all your all pros this season so
hurry to your local Honda dealer today
and test drive the Honda Pilot okay so
the Rich Eisen show news update ok if
Chris Brock Manhasset and the man who
loved Godspell on Broadway
Pat McAfee is here on the returns no I
deal with okay we're gonna start with
Odell Beckham so the first soundbite
here was yesterday morning on ESPN's
morning show Odell and little Wayne for
some reason sat down with Joe Cena
Anderson and she asked him how he's
feeling with the Giants currently I just
want to be able to be the very best that
I can and I don't feel like I'm given an
opportunity to be the very best that I
can to bring that every single day what
is holding you back I haven't been in
the situation I haven't been in the
place I feel like I can really go out
and do everything that I'm capable of
doing yeah I don't get 20 targets like
some other receivers at the offense is
it the skiing when you talk about your
knife what enough everything at the
moment it's just everything it's just
everything and not to say that it's not
gonna work but at the moment I feel like
I work entirely way to Hawaii
yikes yikes yikes
well ball down yesterday though he had a
pretty good pitcher and Shermer dialed
up a pass for him to throw it to
berkeley you know and he said wise Lil
Wayne I got the part of five thought was
okay
I was pretty good two or three good
heaters on there last week I understand
the relevance thing mm-hmm
but man I just he just got paid to write
Odell just got paid he did and he just
basically sawed down the quarterback the
coach the whole team right and then and
the city is well saying that he really
liked what you've been liking out here
in Los Angeles
well I can't play long after the game
okay let's hear here's what he said I
don't regret anything that I said if it
took that for us to come together as a
team like we did today I could take that
every single time it had been on my
heart and I think all the stuff that was
built up inside it just kind of it came
out in the wrong way and I texted him
and I asked if I could have a minute
just to talk to the team because I feel
like we don't we don't if we're not all
on the same page if it's not authentic
and real and we can all understand each
other
then there's gonna always be
miscommunication so now the texting him
is patched Shermer who he texted and
Shermer said that he did address the
team and he wasn't talking about what
was going on in the team he said that
the locker room handled it is what the
coach said what if someone who's been in
a locker room Pat McAfee what do you
think that means well first of all he
say he didn't regret it and then he had
to give him a team speech that means you
do regret it right that's the first
thing I would tell Beckham is a unique
talent that is just electric factory
when he's on there but whenever you talk
bad about your teammates awkward like I
accidentally posted a picture of Andrew
Luck almost naked in the background and
I was like embarrassed to walk into the
locker room for the next week is that
your like your family your
that's everything like that and
hopefully he said they came together
around that we'll see but that is a bad
look it's bad because I don't like
awkward situations to begin with okay
I don't like awkward situations I don't
enjoy thank God me Starbucks earlier
didn't put enough Splenda in it then you
want to tell him about it I'll just
drink this bitter drink right here to
keep it moving don't have the awkward
situation keep it but when you saw down
your entire team that's an awkward
situation it can't be good I mean
obviously everybody knows Eli ain't got
what do you I used to have but whenever
you just got paid they're looking for
you to be a leader in there and when you
just saw I just don't enjoy I didn't
like it he did pre did just position
himself as a leader saying that if if
that's the reason why I team comes
together good spin zone that's what he
basically said spin zone yeah not a bad
spin so what do you mean by it so again
just what do you think happens in a
locker room who would walk just just
again you're not in there yeah everybody
if something like that had happened in
the Colts locker room who would have
walked up to that receiver and said
something so it takes the vets right so
it takes the vets but when it's one of
the vets doing it it's kind of difficult
right cuz Odell is now a made man for
the Giants he's a rich guy there he's a
veteran there so whenever you have one
of the veterans kind of doing that it
doesn't really lead the way for the
younger guys so it would have to be a
veteran it would have to be like an Eli
Manning who would have to go out to him
hey I heard what you said about us how
about the team we can't do that publicly
that's in-house you know at least until
after the season is over
because now winning football games and
an F L is hard enough dealing with drama
with your highest paid player who is a
little bit dramatic if you think about
the dramatics of Odell Beckham to begin
with but they just got them rich they
just did everything like that now you
got to deal with a little bit of
heightened Real Housewives type
situation happening in there I just
think it was a dumb dumb move it got a
lot of clicks for ESPN I assume but it's
also gonna there's gonna be some
feelings hurt in the locker room I'd
assume which isn't good never good Pat
McAfee here is part of Chris Brockman's
news update that rolls on with Jay Jay
talking to Tim McManus of espn.com not
happy with the play calling yesterday
quote obviously we want to be able to
run the ball early and start that rhythm
early in the beginning of the game if I
remember correctly we had maybe three
carries at the end of the first quarter
with the offensive line we have on this
team running the ball like that doesn't
make sense to me
Wow everybody's calling out Antonio
Brown right Antonio Brown was upset
about not getting a
deep balls Odell Beckham's upset cuz
he's knocking twenty touches a game
which I think he did yesterday he had to
throw then I got JJ coming out and I
think the thing is is when the NFL gets
as big as it is which it is which you by
the way are a big part of by the way
thanks Patrick you should go ahead and
take that stuff it in your belt buckle
and run with it
the NFL is huge so everything that
happens it's in a fishbowl every single
comment nowadays is taken for what it
said and then run with and it's it's
just such an interesting situation
because I don't say back in my day like
I'm an old man but everything is handled
in-house almost until the season's over
at least like I went after our GM after
he got fired because he was a bum I got
one asked right yes and but during I
never won it during the season would
never do it because he's added Drummond
and I'm way too low on the totem pole to
be doing any of that it's always like a
be who you can afford to be type
situation but right now drama seems to
be the common denominator with every NFL
team I'm gonna go off on a couple
tangents here
Gregson did you think he was right for
talking about the footballs and the AFC
Championship game that was such a while
aust by 50 I think hey it was just a
wild wild situation who knows if
anything was with the balls I don't get
the feeling I only have the K balls
right but the fact that they beat us by
50 and then it got blown out of
proportion this whole thing that
happened I just I think if you ask any
player on the Colts we were kind of
embarrassed to be a part of the whole
thing our name kept getting brought up
every single time I was brought up but I
just I didn't agree with a lot that that
GM did to be honest a lot of things
whether it was handling people handling
situations he just was he was a Mama's
like a robot wasn't an actual human
didn't really think much so I would say
it disagree and is it not
am I not am I mistaken or am I not
correct agile in the game a pretty big
fumble in that game out here in LA I
think you get to see it there isn't a
lot of self awareness in the world is
the home I think now obviously obviously
in LA the lack of self awareness capital
of the world yeah you don't want these
bird scooters you got to keep your head
on a swivel there's a near-death at any
given time ain't nobody paying attention
but self awareness seems to be at an
all-time low in the society that we're
all right what else you got
injury recap here Greg Olson says he is
expected to come back this week but that
he does expect to have her surgery at
the end of the season Rashad Higgins
sprained MCL for Cleveland expected to
miss two games Ian Rapoport says Leonard
fournette expected to remain sidelines
for week 6 against Dallas week six game
that is jaguars now three and two dallas
two and three at the jones mahal holy
crap that's a big week six games
according the world Gerry world yeah
according to Nelson the Patriots have
been in contact with Mike Gillis Lee
remember he was cut by them early in the
season recently released by the Saints
and Matt Reed has suffered a mid to high
ankle sprain looks like he's out this
week
yeah well Gillis Lee being put out on
the street is not surprised with Ingram
coming back tonight right and with me
needing 17 points from Alvin camara I'm
genuinely concerned that I love that
guys by the way but camara yeah isn't he
great love them he's got the little bull
nose thing too
uh yeah they did the ring yeah I love
him I'm a big fan of the tomorrow I am
too Julie what an animal is it America
Mars chimera by the way Brees tonight by
the end of tonight Drew Brees will have
the following records most completions
most passing yards check most 400 yard
passing games checked most 300-yard
passing games and he's like five foot
eight he's wild we were talking about
Brees being put on Mount Rushmore when
it's satin said and done of quarterbacks
quarterback Mount Rushmore
very professional - I got a chance to go
to a Pro Bowl he was there yeah he was a
captain Pro Bowl like loved everything
about it you know what I mean like he
was a very sore you on the Pro Bowl I we
had to drive three hours on the desert
for practice we just lost to the
Patriots by 50 I was about done with it
I was like I thought we're gonna be in
Hawaii we're in Arizona what are we
doing here this is an honor of a
lifetime I'm very proud of it but this I
just want to go golf but Brees was the
exact opposite exact opposite super
professional he's enough granted him and
his stupid baby is the only reason why I
don't have a Super Bowl ring
so maybe I hold a little bitterness
towards that but Drew Brees is an
incredible human and there's a guy that
was told no basically his whole career
right too short of course shoulders bad
get out of here see you later
yeah now he's the guy yeah the
headphones on come on you can't you just
lost the Super Bowl but come on hey kids
especially that one in particular
cocaine Drew Brees probably great dad
great kid I probably I assume I don't
know why we don't know the he's winning
footballs at the taped up son on a fence
well it's a new era don't you ever talk
about Tim McAfee like that awesome game
Texas came back to because I had the
whole game beat Oklahoma Oklahoma is
fired defensive coordinator Mike Stoops
Wow as a result he's out the school
announced Ruffin McNeil is gonna take
over being the Sooners assistant head
coach by the way Ruffin McNeil I think
also has a great show on Disney Junior
yeah like a great animated show Baker
the kicker also has a great show on
Disney by the way that lit up Twitter
kicker how about how he looked right
beforehand to her he gave like this
small wing anyways he was a career six
four nine also I mean you know better
than anybody else you gotta have
confidence when you're kicking you got
you're about to make it to the kicker
your next kicks your best kick you're
about to end the internet you know that
Red River Rivalry or whatever yes that
guy's gonna be able to sign pictures
there for the rest of his life correct
hook on okay what's that let's hear from
could be real quick he talked yesterday
finally after after the epic fight
Saturday night wanna say sorry to
athletic commission Nevada sorry to
Vegas I know this is not my best side
you know this is not my best side you
know I'm humor bin and like I know
understand how people can talk about I
jump on the cage you know what about he
talk boy
about my religion he talked about my
country he talked about my father he
come to Brooklyn and he broke bus he
almost killed couple people what about
this this is a respect sport you know
this is not trash-talking sport
this is respect so like I told you
before guys I wanna change this game he
started off like um I'm sorry I'm so
humble but he came to Brooklyn and broke
bus man almost killed people he says
that was me MMA is not a trash-talking
sport I missed something I did I do
believe if you watch like the the dojo
like there's always like a bowing and
handshaking and things like that but if
you want to make money off you got to
promote it and their only way to do that
is this yeah yes to is to get a
pinstripe suit with curse words to make
up that's right which is what money
Mayweather honors the best at it that's
proper look I I don't know they may take
away his belt but then they'll give it
back
I mean let's just all take a beat make
sure that nobody got killed let's see
what the the authorities the actual
people in charge in Vegas are gonna do
take a beat and then
if nothing else comes from this whole
thing the word fook is one of the best
words of all time of all time Dana White
did say today that Conor McGregor has
already called him asking for an
immediate rematch of course against
khabib so this is all WWE rematch clause
it's happening promos being cut after
beforehand the authorities being called
a couple of MBA inés before we leave the
sun's fired GM Ryan McDonagh this
morning it's kind of a shock with the
seasons set to start next week before
the suns thought a basketball team
there's another question kind of my
point also bad news for San Antonio star
Jonte Murray tore his ACL really bummin
is there for Spurs what a so after they
had gotten rid of Tony all right
so Parker's gone Ginobili is gone
Duncan's not walking through that door
wise god wise up in Toronto laughing by
the way in Toronto right Parker's in
Parkers and Charlotte Charlotte looked
very weird in the pre
she isn't seeing that Jersey yeah the
Rosen's got to be like are you kidding
me this would be the one time that the
Spurs aren't the Spurs yeah he shows up
walking through that door bummer that is
a bummer this is your the West though is
it Vince what this is Golden State
LeBron they were still a playoff team
let's go don't forget they're gonna get
Houston pan Houston Oklahoma City
Portland javis is awesome Indiana Pacers
about to make a run let's go Victor
Oladipo do you go to those games no a
big fan when they win the old city seems
to be happier which is good the Indians
got out of a bases-loaded jam on the top
of the third it's now bottom three still
scoreless in the ALDS back more with
Patrick McAfee hey of West Virginia fan
by the way
West Virginia fans are not happy with me
I'll explain why when we come up yeah we
hate you rich
all right welcome back to the show the
Rich Eisen show store opened for
business check out on Rich Eisen shoka
more on the Rich Eisen show app t shirts
polos caps mugs backpacks and all with
the Rich Eisen show logo special this
month limited time only punters are
people to t-shirts you guys are in the
March game o hema merged and the merch
game for years we just finally got the
Rich Eisen showing it merch games a good
business to be in well you got the for
the brand t-shirts but the Rich Eisen
show hunters two people two t-shirts you
can get all different sorts of team
colors I gave them one close pack I gave
patent one close to the Colts colors a
little to Honolulu blue for his taste so
you just we're gonna get you in the West
Virginia colors that is that sound what
WVU you said people hate you over there
maybe get you back on your side me too
by the way Michael Brantley with a sac
fly bottom three Cleveland's that one
nothing they don't hate you
the reason mother upset with me as I was
going on this whole spiel before we
brought you on Pat that if Notre Dame
goes undefeated I think that a one loss
SEC Championship loser
so if Alabama beats Georgia Georgia
beats Alabama in a close game that the
loser of that game would still get a
spot in the playoffs over undefeated
Ohio over an undefeated Notre Dame if
Ohio State and Clemson have the other
spots and I forgot about the fact that
West Virginia's currently yeah
undefeated and it's a big 12 top of the
mountain I know and if they run the
table beating Texas in Oklahoma and when
that cockamamie useless stupid
championship game as well that what if
there what if every single one of them
is undefeated what happens then WVU
width or you just changed the freakin
rules and have an 18 playoff how many
times have I said that you're like no we
don't need that absolutely absolute
communist the best teams are given
Sunday Saturday ish Saturday Thursday
Wednesday fans are throwing stuff at
radios and televisions we're not even
mentioned in them too so why wouldn't
they get in and then throw in you know
your runner-up in the Big Ten also throw
in the runner-up to could be Michigan
could be Penn State could be Wisconsin
what what that's an A Team cornucopia
that you cannot deny I want to see
Alabama beat Michigan by 50 that's not
interesting
Alabama's gonna be there buddy by 50
that's gonna happen ever
- is gonna win the heisman trophy not
throwing a fourth-quarter touched up ass
until the iron ball he looks like Pat
white by the way he looks like Pat white
with Alabama said to us are you serious
I was a little taller and thinner though
what's that that was a little taller and
thinner very similar playing styles
though both playing lefty helps out a
lot but you watch him and I got a front
row seat to watch Pat Whitey's entire
career yes he led me to an all-time
leading scorer record w a little big
deal but he - it looks a lot like Pat
white but with Alabama behind them which
is difference yeah that's every 5-star
recruit in America every all-americans
why if Alabama loses to Georgia in the
SEC championship game they're absolutely
making the final four over any of these
undefeated teams that I'm a kid talking
about and if you guys sit there go no
way come on can't keep an undefeated
team out you guys are nuts it's happened
twice already
next Saban had a hard knock show on ESPN
if you don't think that is good Alabama
will be anywhere they need to be for
ratings for college football for Nick
Saban's dominance that's just the way
it's gonna go
there's no question yeah he's bowed you
watch a show did you watch the show I
did not
it's kind of weird when you say Ben had
a bunch of like kids on his boat on his
back he wrote her name is a bigger
national brand on Alabama
I agree that's just the fact Notre Dame
is a bigger national brand fact I think
1990 right there hear that
notre dame's bigger than Alabama you
think national brand hundred
professional brand yeah over I think
that's at the very 21st century
Sensibility oh my god self-awareness at
an all-time low
right there that's what I'm talking
about which one me of them them
Alabama's huge I had a show a training
camp show they have a the ESPN wanted to
be in bed with Nick Saban yeah which
makes them a national brand only I'm
sure it was only watched in the south
Notre Dame is coast to coast top to
bottom you know we're doing right now
we're having a hot debate
yeah that's great split screen it with
the topic trooper bottom triple box it
and start barking at each other like
that quad bikes that might be in your
might be in your future professionally I
don't know I don't like the awkward
moments some awkward moments here we had
only one awkward moment you and I in the
last hour can you pick can you peg which
one do you want have for my dad that's
the one okay the bald-headed guy on the
left side of the screen is stupid so now
it's awkward wrong had it for a second
um I don't know you kind of did it right
I got clowns to the left of me Joker's
to the right Here I am stuck in the
middle with a great take Pat McAfee
doing a stealers wheel right there man I
take it back you want in a full circle
back to your Pittsburgh days right here
we go you know I mean it's right Don
Patrick thank you thanks for having me
here
yeah this has been just been delightful
the third hour I had to show those three
hours yeah third hour gets tough a
little yeah that's where we had to bring
in the specialists come on bring me and
I'll bring the juice in Guzzi well you
said you already did this morning when
you woke up I keep the juice that sounds
like it's juice yeah three dollars and
33 cents that's all the greatest comedic
sports documentary of all times gonna
cost you at Pat McAfee show.com every
purchase that the documentary gets you a
ticket to the greatest raffle of all
time thrilled the groats mm-hmm it's
correct the growth we had an actual
press release that went out to a bunch
of places this morning and they had to
say the groats did they really that was
a funny situation so throat did any did
any news organizations refuse your
release just on that on that I think all
of the loan I think principal I've
gotten zero reaction from it so I think
we $380 well spent but the greatest
raffle of all time is something that you
should enter for three dollars and 33
cents potential world's Erie's tickets
superb owl tickets WrestleMania tickets
all these things also a thousand dollars
free play on a gambling website movement
watching sunglasses autographed Adam
Vinatieri game-worn Jersey and also
chance of job shadow Nick Moore Aldo
Patrick McAfee for the brand everybody
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience